in bird culture this is considered a
dick move everybody is Charlie a bunch
of you been messaging me about Rick and
Morty don't worry Dan Harmon went on a
big tear explaining what's going on it's
actually pretty rare for show runners to
do that so I'll explain what he said
what it means there is no cause for
alarm just to lighten the mood we'll say
there's a giveaway for official Rick and
Morty merchandise from their store all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
so it has been a weird couple of days
for Rick and Morty bands I've started to
see comments on my other videos that
have nothing to do with Rick and Morty
asking me if it's canceled
and I had absolutely no idea what was
going on till I started poking around a
little bit and then last night Dan
Harmon started super posting on Twitter
like all across his Twitter feed calling
out crazy websites that you've never
heard of that we're saying that Rick and
Morty had been canceled so suddenly the
light bulb went on and I was like oh
okay this is what people are asking
about so right off the bat that is 100%
fake we're totally getting Rick and
Morty season 3 so I'll explain what Dan
Harmon said because he goes after these
people in a pretty funny way so it all
started with this post here I'm so
fascinated and confused about how these
rumor campaigns start are they organic
does someone profit very clearly someone
is profiting off of making fans freaked
out about a show maybe I miss perceived
attraction this concept has because it's
the second article I've seen in 3 days
this one source is the first I'm not mad
at all it doesn't hurt me and Justin in
any way for someone to spread that lie
but I imagine it scares the out of
fans anyway season 3 is coming we took
too long riding it they're finishing
drawing it it's coming as said summer
that's real press Coffey and makes a bit
of a Trump joke there if you don't know
what that is don't worry he's just
saying that it's coming soon then Justin
roiland chimes in I'm so sorry guys
sorry about this super factual
information Dan Harmon and I are so
sorry for this totally believable and
true story with like the fakest headline
you've ever seen from a facebook page
that looks totally legit it has Rick and
Morty in the title so it must be a
so Facebook is actually developing a
real-life meeseeks box to blow crap like
this out of the water but then on top of
that this morning Dan Harmon went on a
tear a hungover thread where I address
Rick and Morty devotees because I feel
bad for any fan worrying about any show
threatening issue Justin and I are very
regretful about the season taking way
too long I want to explain what happened
because it's way less dramatic than you
might ever imagine post internet TV
audiences are so used to finding out
there's an intriguing confusing intense
reason for delays Christ knows if you've
ever seen my name on the Internet I've
only got myself to blame for an
association with intrigue confusion
drama that's just a reference to all the
problems that he had during community
when he got fired off the show because
of all the behind-the-scenes drama
that's water under the bridge that was a
long time ago he goes on but the truth
in this case is so very boring I will
put it to you as objectively as I can
though we aren't talking about an auto
plant the reason season 3 took so long
is because it took long to write because
it was season three of a show that we
were scared to make worse than season 2
or season 1 it's a common yet old
phenomenon tail-chasing perfectionism
overthinking one problem is that any
description you pick for it is going to
have a falseness if I say we over
thought someone else could say well no
we thought the right amount
it's like talking about religion or
something it feels like I think two
writers sacrilegious and effective to
open the creative process and poke and
label but don't worry about the content
because the reason over thought slows
you down is you just do way more
versions of the stuff than needed you
usually end up back where you started so
as far as I can tell although I'm too
close to it he's talking about too close
to the material like he's too obsessed
with Rick and Morty it's just another
good season it took way too long to
write because it just seems like the
same stuff that took way less time to
write that's it boring answer this is
where it starts to get a little bit fun
as I speak more articles are coming out
about me and Justin fighting because
it's a
boring reason for season to take so long
and because I'm Dan Harmon so it's a
smart first guess it just happens to be
hilariously not true even in the
slightest if you do know me at all and
you know that if justin and i had ever
thought not only would we not be able to
keep it a secret
we'd be all too eager to share it with
you also that's not what would make the
show slow down fighting would probably
have been a good idea it might have sped
us up so that's it i shouldn't have
started a thread when I need to pack for
airport but that's it we took too long
riding totes regrets and we look back
and we talk to each other about how we
can avoid it happening again and I'm
pretty sure it won't because it happened
that's how it works you do something you
don't know you're doing and then you're
like oh I did that and then you do
otherwise I don't know if any danger to
the show itself comes from you believing
Justin and I are fighting and the show
is gone forever but like I said it
breaks my heart to think of some kid
reading these articles after all the
energy he's put into the fandom the show
by my metric which is people seeing my
t-shirts and saying I love that show has
the craziest reach of anything I've been
a part of so it makes sense that when
you take something that loved and delay
it this long and let the internet simmer
you get this stuff we're flattered by it
and thankful to you all and can't wait
for you to see a season 3 and also
justin has a piece of that I'm
going to fist fight I love the way that
he and that sentence he's trying to
explain what's going on behind the
scenes how it's still coming how
everybody shouldn't worry out how he
loves the fandom then takes a hard left
turn like Oh Mia just said we're gonna
fistfight big time season 9 more seasons
morning 9 more seasons until I get that
different sexual on soccer ninety seven
more years morning I want that exact
8.40 so there you have it straight from
the council of ricks but you'll probably
see in the next couple of weeks is more
of those funny promos that they've been
releasing
the genius place they typically don't
post trailers the way that normal TV
shows post trailers every couple weeks
they usually just release promos from
behind the scenes but they have finished
a bunch of episodes it's just that they
have to wait till a certain amount or
done before they start running them so
that they can air them in blocks but as
they release new information I'll do new
videos whatever drops don't worry leave
all your bonus video requests in the
comments below there's new flash there's
new Game of Thrones that I'll be posting
later today I'll announce the Rick and
Morty giveaway winner the next time I
post Rick and Morty but while you wait
for everything you can click here for
all those promo videos and you can click
here for brand new Game of Thrones thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
[Applause]